let's get right into audience questions
for the week first one is hey David I
get Michael Bloomberg is doing okay in
the polls but what's the point of him
campaigning for the presidency he can't
win he's nearly 80 years old he's merely
hemorrhaging cash what is the point of
this entire thing so I think there's a
couple different things going on number
one the spending of the money so given
that Michael Bloomberg is running for
him the spending of the money he
probably sees as a better and more
efficient way to get his message
directly to voters then participation in
the debates after having an individual
donation infrastructure so he's chosen
to forgo individual donations he's
spending a whole bunch of money it could
be a hundred and fifty million by now
could could be even more I don't know
that we have the latest tally and he
believes that he has a good message and
he is choosing to go directly to voters
and that explains the spending of the
money if you have 55 billion spending a
hundred million or two hundred million
or 300 million these are unconscionable
amounts of money for 99.99% of the
population or or more but to Michael
Bloomberg it's really it's barely
anything particularly when he's nearly
80 years old and he has all the money
and in his kids I don't know anything
about his family but his kids I'm sure
have all the money they could ever need
so the spending of the money you have to
think about it as like spending pennies
and that's effectively what he is doing
secondly I think the strategy of running
at all because again if the thing
doesn't change drastically
he is obviously not going to be the
nominee there's a gamble that Biden
fails and people get scared of voting
Bernie or voting Warren and Bloomberg is
there with name recognition and having
built up a campaign infrastructure as
well as just blasting out hundreds of
millions of dollars in ads now it may
not work because the obvious alternative
to an establishment Democrat like Biden
is not to go to the guy who got in late
hasn't been in any of the debates and
was a Republican for a long time in his
life I think they go to Buda edge or
they go to Amy Klobuchar to fill the
establishment role if Biden were to
totally falter I do believe that
underlying
all of this I believe Michael Bloomberg
is sincere that he wants to remove
Donald Trump at all costs and there was
the concern of well Bloomberg's in there
because he's super rich and he wants to
protect his own wealth
there's probably ways in which that's
true but he may also be wanting to
protect merely the structures that allow
him to make money rather than avoiding a
wealth tax personally because I read
over the weekend that he said he would
support whoever the Democratic nominee
ultimately is including Elizabeth Warren
whose wealth tax would directly affect
Michael Bloomberg and I'm sure he
doesn't believe that her wealth tax will
become a reality and that's probably a
good assessment he says he would vote
for Bernie so on and so forth so I don't
want another billionaire president I've
not seen evidence that Michael Bloomberg
is acting in bad faith and of course
it's what his candidacy really is is not
evidence of a guy acting in bad faith
it's just evidence of why the money in
politics system that we have is so
corrosive because he switched from being
a Republican to a Democrat during Donald
Trump's tenure bought his way in without
being in a single debate and his polling
at last check something like five or six
percent I don't think he's a bad faith
actor but he does show us why the system
we have doesn't work and why it should
be very quickly changed I also by the
way I would love to get a phone call
when we do live calls from a Michael
Bloomberg supporter I jokingly tweeted
over the weekend that I met a real Amy
Klobuchar supporter in real life and I
in in person I don't think I know anyone
who's supporting Klobuchar or Biden I
know a couple people I'm friends with on
Facebook who are supporting mayor Pete I
don't I've not talked to anyone who's
supporting Michael Bloomberg and I would
love to get a call from them during live
calls next week so if you're supporting
Bloomberg I want to hear from you is
that issue oriented is it personality is
it you want a billionaire to face off
against Trump or what exactly is it that
you see as appealing about Michael
Bloomberg